are you prepared to embark on an
electrifying journey into the world of
Google Cloud platform and unlock the
gateway to unparalleled possibilities in
the realm of cloud computing well brace
yourself for an extraordinary adventure
with gcp basics
the Ultimate key to revolutionize your
business and Propel it towards a future
of Limitless Innovation like never
before
a world where your business effortlessly
source to new heights of efficiency
adapt seamlessly to any Challenge and
Sparks groundbreaking discoveries
welcome to the realm of gcp where
imagination transforms into reality and
the power of the cloud becomes your
Ultimate Ally but here's the exciting
twist prepare to be stunned as I unveil
an awe-inspiring fact gcp stands tall as
a Titan in the global cloud computing
landscape commanding an astounding
Market's share of over 20 and hold on
tight because by 2023 the global public
Cloud Market is projected to surpass a
staggering 800 billion dollars unlocking
a realm of unprecedented opportunities
the demand for gcp services is
skyrocketing higher than ever before and
the time for you to seize the Limitless
potential is now now let's dive into the
numbers that hold the key to your future
success the ones that will ignite your
career like a blazing comet GCB
professionals are an immense demand
commanding top tier salaries entry level
positions alone boasts jaw dropping
salary ranges of seventy thousand
dollars to one twenty thousand dollars
per year as you send the ranks mastering
gcp and gaining valuable experience even
more exhilarating opportunities await
you in this rapidly expanding field so
if you're ready to embark on a career
path buzzing with excitement Innovation
and boundless possibilities look no
further then simply learn Celtic
post-graduate program in cloud computing
focusing on gcp this comprehensive
program equips you with the knowledge
and skills needed to navigate the vast
landscape of cloud computing with
unwavering confidence Unleash Your
Potential as you delve into the depths
of gcp architecture conquer deployment
models fortify security like an embedded
triple Fortress and master migration
strategies that leave a lasting impact
discover how to harness the full suit of
sap services to construct not just
scalable applications but true
masterpieces of Technology don't let
this once in a lifetime opportunity slip
through your fingers ignite your career
and join the ranks of triumphant cloud
computing professionals click the link
in the description to uncover the
wonders of this course immerse yourself
in all inspiring success stories from
our satisfied Learners who have
harnessed the Limitless potential of gcp
to achieve the extraordinary the future
resides in the cloud and the gcp eagerly
awaits your arrival
so are you ready to seize it and Ascend
to unimaginable Heights
I will be permanently moving to Europe
with my family so simply learn this
course has helped me back a great job
offered there will be the 60 salary high
we cannot wait to start our new life in
Finland we are also excited hey I am
and I am currently living in Algeria I
am working as Chief Information
Technology officer at aristiles after
working for 23 years in I.T sector in
Algeria I felt that my career had become
stagnant here I wanted to experience
what is like to live in Europe so I
started applying to various jobs there
as someone who is responsible for making
the decision I wanted to upgrade my
skills I also realized that to get a new
job I needed to have a personal
certification in cloud computing so last
year I started the postgraduate program
in cloud computing in association with
Caltech constant video it's not easy to
get access to Caltech but simply didn't
provided that with this course I had the
choice to study while I can tune it with
my job
either Technologies like ews and Azure
during the course luckily my new
employers were looking for someone who
knew these Technologies I have just
completed the course but my New York
Lawyers were aware that guy was taking
this course and that is how I got this
new job offer with 60 percent salary
hike in Finland I will be leading the
cloud computing unit of my new company
I am really excited not just for myself
but for my family as well I have 30
dollars I think I will be able to help
them with their higher studies in Europe
as a father you always want to make
decision that have a positive impact on
your children as for me I am going to
live my dream now I think dreams come
true when you work hard to achieve them
unleash the magic of cloud computing and
its platforms like ews Azure and gcp and
witness the floodgates open as your
website attracts a tidal wave of organic
traffic and enjoys unrival success in
the digital realm so let's get started
in this session we learn about Google
Cloud platform wherein we will learn
about what is cloud computing why Google
Cloud platform what is gcp that is
Google Cloud platform Google Cloud
platform domains about a use case that
is Ferrero use case and also a quick
demo on using services from Google Cloud
platform so when we talk about Google
Cloud platform we also need to know what
is cloud computing so cloud computing is
the use of hardware and software
components to deliver a service to a
network users can access these files and
applications and services provided by a
cloud provider from any device that has
access to Internet in short cloud
computing is a way where cloud provider
provides access to different services
such as resources and when we talk about
resources here we talk about Computing
we talk about memory we talk about
processing power we talk about storage
and we also talk about different
Services which Cloud providers make
available for the users now that allows
us for automatic software integration
backup and restoring data unlimited
storage capacity having a reliable use
of different services and having a cost
efficient solution now we know that
cloud computing models there are
different service models so you have
platform as a service you have
infrastructure as a service and you have
software as a service and these are the
prominent models which are offered by
different Cloud providers such as Google
Cloud such as Google you have Amazon you
have Azure and also some organizations
build their own private clouds using
open source openstack let's focus more
on Google Cloud platform and what it has
to offer and how it is gaining
popularity in the market with different
organizations which would want to work
on a cloud platform or which would want
to work on an infrastructure which is
modernized so when we talk about cloud
computing this is one of the approach
which organizations can take to
instantaneously benefit from
modernization using different Services
different platforms and also newer
Technologies for their various
requirements such as scalability or
dynamic businesses
before we get into Google Cloud platform
it is also good to understand where you
can find some useful resources about
Google Cloud platform and here you have
a website which is from your Google
Cloud so this is cloudacademy.com
Library slash Google and here you can
create a free account now that would
give you just seven days trial but that
has a lot of videos which talk about
your Google Cloud platform and
Essentials and it has various
certification related videos which you
can access and then after seven days
after you have tried you can obviously
go for a paid account where you can take
detailed learning from here now this is
your training Library which shows you a
different Cloud providers such as Amazon
Microsoft SEO gcp and then you have
various other topics which are specifics
to organization you can obviously look
at the pricing and you can also look at
resources which will give you a good
experience in learning from these videos
you can also create a free account which
I will walk you through later so you can
create a free account on
cloud.google.com now when I say free
account that basically means it allows
you to create an account and every user
who creates an account gets a 300 free
credit which can be used to practice
brush up your skills and also explore
and learn about different Google Cloud
products which are offered by Google
now coming back to our Google Cloud
platform let's understand why Google
Cloud platform so Google Cloud platform
is popular for many reasons now let us
see few of most important reasons why it
stands out
when you talk about pricing pricing is
one of the significant factors that make
Google Cloud Stand Out Among the other
Cloud providers
it offers a monthly pricing plan which
is billed according to monthly usage and
when we talk about billing here the
billing can be in hours it can be in
minutes and it can also be in seconds
there are different options when you
talk about your pricing which can be
found from your Google Cloud web page
now pricing could be based on preemptive
machines pricing could be based on
reserved instances or reserved resources
I'll show you the link where you can
find more details on pricing part of it
so Google Cloud really has various
pricing options which help customers in
their different requirements whether
they would go for any of the service
models such as infrastructure as a
service platform as a service or even
software as a service one more
attractive thing about Google Cloud
pricing is that it provides committed
use discounts
for example under this scheme you can
purchase a specific amount of virtual
CPU course and memory for up to 57
discount off regular prices if you
commit usage for either one or three
years now this is just one option there
are various such options which you can
learn about from the Google clouds page
and that really suits different
customers for their different
requirements
now when we talk about speed we don't
need to really challenge this aspect
when it comes to Google services so
Google provides its Google cloud and
Google app customer speed up to 10
terabytes because of its faster cable
system there are different kind of
machines which can be used if you are
talking about computation if you are
talking about memory hungry applications
or even storage intensive workloads okay
all in all speed is one of the defining
characteristics of Google cloud services
the cable has connections over us West's
course main cities in Japan and even
major hubs in Asia this speed enhances
performances and leads to customer
satisfaction now when we talk about
customers any or every customer would
prefer to have low latency High
throughput Based Services they would
want to use higher speeds to process
their data in as less time as possible
Google provides a low latency Network
infrastructure in fact you can say that
when you are using Google cloud services
you are using the services from the same
infrastructure which Google uses for its
popular services such as Google search
or even YouTube which is one of the
second largest repository which can be
accessed for videos now when we talk
about Big Data big data is data which is
very complex has lot of other
characteristics such as your volume you
have velocity you have variety you have
velocity validity volatility virility
and so on so if an organization has is
working on Big Data Google Cloud can be
a better choice because Google has many
Innovative tools for cloud warehousing
for example such as bigquery and even
real-time data processing tools such as
data flow bigquery is a data warehouse
that allows massive processing of data
at high speeds basically working on your
structured data Google also has launched
some new machine learning from
artificial intelligence tools now there
are various other services which we can
which we can use from Google Cloud
platform but let's understand what is
Google Cloud platform and what are some
of the services even the services which
are not less tested here can be found in
your console from Google Cloud so what
is Google Cloud platform gcp it is a set
of Cloud Computing Services provided by
Google that runs on the same
infrastructure as I mentioned that
Google uses for its end user products
like YouTube Gmail and even Google
search the various set of services
offered by Google Cloud platform are so
you have Services which are specific to
Computing requirements and again in
Computing you have various different
options available you have machines
which are compute optimized machines
which are memory optimized machines
which are storage optimized and also we
have certain machines such as preemptif
which basically means that you could get
a machine to work on at a far lesser
price than any other machine but when we
talk about preemptive these are the
machines which can be requested on
demand and they can be taken back by
Google at any time you have networking
related Services which can be very
useful when you are setting up your
applications or your services across
Globe you also have different Services
which are specific to machine learning
and organizations which would be
interested in working on machine
learning or artificial intelligence
would be really interested in using
these Services there are also innovative
solutions to work on big data and Big
Data related Technologies now when we
talk about Google Cloud platform domains
so we can break down these Services into
specifics such as you have compute now
the compute service allows for computing
and hosting the cloud
now when you talk about Computing here
there are different services such as app
engine you have compute engine you have
kubernetes you have Cloud functions and
Cloud run when you talk about storage
and database so the storage and database
service allows application to store
media files backups or other file like
objects now various Services Under This
are as follows you have cloud storage
Cloud SQL Cloud bigtable for
unstructured data you have Cloud spanner
cloud data store persistent disks and
Cloud memory store when we talk about
networking the networking service allows
us to load balanced traffic across
resources now as I mentioned earlier
resources could be your different
resources which you would be using from
a cloud platform such as your devices
your instances memory optimize or CPU
optimized instances us or other
resources creating DNS records and much
more so various Services Under This are
VPC that stands for virtual private
Cloud you have Cloud load balancing
Cloud armor Cloud CDN you have Cloud
interconnect DNS and network service
tiers when we talk about the big data
service this allows us to process and
query big data in Cloud now various
Services under these are as follows you
have bigquery cloud cloud data proc
Cloud composer cloud data lab cloud data
prep Cloud Pub sub which is publishing
subscribing system you have cloud data
studio now you also have the developer
tools and developer Tools service
includes tools related to development of
an application now various Services
under these are as follows that is you
have Cloud SDK software development kit
you have deployment manager Cloud Source
Repository and Cloud test lab when we
talk about identity and security which
is one of the primary concerns for any
organization or any user who would be
interested in using a cloud platform
Google Cloud really has taken care of
this so when you talk about identity and
security domain this deals with Security
Services now various Services here are
Cloud identity you have identity and
access management that is cloud IAM you
have identity aware proxies you have
cloud data loss prevention API security
key enforcement Key Management Service
and many more
you also have cloud services which are
related to internet of things so very
much would be used by organizations who
would be working on iot devices or the
data generated by these devices so
various Services here are Cloud iot Core
you have Edge TPU and Cloud iot also
when we talk about Cloud AI that is
artificial intelligence this comprises
of services related to machine learning
and much more so you have Cloud Auto ml
Cloud TPU Cloud machine learning engine
job Discovery dialogue flow Enterprise
natural language Cloud text to speech
and much more
if you would be interested in Services
related to API platform then there are
different Services Under This category
or this domain so you have Maps platform
you have APG API platform monetization
developer portal analytics that is API
analytics APG sends Cloud endpoints and
service infrastructure so these are some
of the listing of services under each
Cloud platform domain now let's look at
Ferrero use case and let's also
understand what was done here so Ferrero
is one of the famous chocolate and ranks
third among worldwide chocolate and
confectionary producers it was found in
1946 in Italy I'm sure you would have
seen the Ferrero chocolates when you
would have gone out to buy some
chocolates so the challenges here was
that Ferrero as we know is sold in every
supermarket and is known for its quality
once the prisoners grew some issues
arose right and that's what happens when
the business grows you have issues
popping up which could be related to the
volume of data the speed with which the
data is getting generated the variety of
data and also looking at your platforms
which support different Dynamic
applications or your scalability
requirements performance requirements
and so on
so it needed data storage processing and
Analysis system for a wide customer
database
there was a huge gap between the company
and the people who bought its goods
because the company relied on data given
sales outlets now that's one of the
challenge Ferrero wanted to create a
digital ecosystem where there was a
point of contact with its customers and
also a foundation for an Innovative
data-driven marketing strategy what was
the solution here so one of the service
of cloud platforms or Google Cloud
platform is bigquery and this was an
answer to ferrero's challenges since it
was capable of hyper fast and efficient
data analysis as a solution now as I
mentioned bigquery is a data warehouse
which allows you to store structured
data now this could directly be used as
a service where you could store in any
amount of data and you would not be
paying for storage so there are
different pricing models and for data up
to one terabytes you would not be
charged anything and if you would be
accessing the data that is reading the
data or processing the data from
bigquery that's where the pricing model
kicks in
Now using Google Cloud's bigquery
business analysts of Ferrero were able
to store and analyze massive data sets
in a very reliable fast and affordable
manner
consumer behavior and sales pattern data
reports were easy to build and automate
and the analysis also followed Ferrero
to adopt advertising across various
marketing channels to serve the customer
needs in a better way what was the
result
they could divide their database into
real-time actionable consumer clusters
to generate more accurate user profiles
Ferrero was also able to personalize its
marketing strategies to match the user
needs
now Google Cloud platform completely
tailored the website mobile content and
advertising and created a very cost
effective media by strategy now these
were some Basics on Google Cloud now as
I said you can always find a lot of
details about pricing about services and
also all the services are accessible in
your free trial account now let me just
walk you through here so one is you
could always find details on
documentation on each of these services
so if I would click on getting started
you have quick start which basically
shows you short tutorials you have
trainings and you have also
certifications now if we click on quick
start now that takes me to this page
which shows me
quick starts or if you would want to
understand about different projects if
you would want to look into the
documentation of creating a Linux
virtual machine or storing a file and
sharing it deploying a container Docker
container image and so on so you have a
lot of quick starts here you can also
look at Cloud minute
on the same page on the right side you
have docs and once you click on that it
takes you to these links now this shows
you build Solutions which shows your top
use cases best practices all the
solutions it's always good to learn from
these use cases which are available and
here you have different feature products
and all the different Services which
Google Cloud offers now you can click on
featured products and that basically
shows you a list of these products now
here we have all the solutions which you
can look at architecture database
Enterprise level big data and Analysis
gaming related internet of things and so
on now if you go down here it shows you
featured products and that shows you
some of the important products such as
compute engine which is belonging to the
compute domain you have Cloud run you
have anthos which is for migration and
basically Cloud adoption when
organizations would want to move from
on-premise to cloud-based Solutions you
have Vision AI you have cloud storage
now that basically allows you to store
any kind of data whether that's an
object so this is acting as an object
storage you have Cloud SQL which is
basically a ready to use service where
you would be using MySQL postgres or any
other SQL Server database Services you
have bigquery which is a data warehouse
which basically allows you to store your
structured data and then you have your
AI and machine learning related products
so you have automl Vision AI video AI
text to speech speech to text and so on
now you also have different platform
accelerators which can be used and in
any of these cases for example if I
would click on compute engine which is a
featured product from Google Cloud now
that shows you basically your quick
starts using your Linux machines how-to
guides which tells you completely
working on a VM instance
or working on storage working on
persistent disks and so on and it shows
you the documentation here now you also
have products and pricing option which
you can see for GCB pricing and you
could straight away go to the pricing
you could be looking at Solutions which
talks about infrastructure modernization
now this is something which
organizations are interested in when
they would want to move from their
on-premise solution to your Google Cloud
now here I can say for example I click
on infrastructure modernization you can
always find some case studies what are
the different solutions we have here
right when you talk about Google Cloud
so you can always click on see Solutions
and you can look at VM migration or sap
Cloud right why Google Cloud what it can
be used for VMware as a service or HPC
that is high performance Computing and
about these services we will learn in
detail later now I can go back on the
same page where I was clicking on the
services so you have quick starts you
have how-to guides you have deep
understanding of different concepts
right and here if I click on all how to
guides so that shows me what are the
different ways in which you can work
with compute engine and working with
different instances although it's quite
exhaustive content but then if you
follow steadily then you can learn a lot
about Google Cloud now here I can just
go back so this is just giving you some
idea on the different products which are
available from Google Cloud looking into
different sections finding right
documentation here right and you can
always look into each one of these in
detail for each product which Google
Cloud offers
now if we scroll down we could see all
the options or all the domains which we
see here right let me just go back
because we got into Solutions now we
have quick starts right and then you can
basically scroll all the way down to
look at Cloud SDK which can be set up on
your Windows machine like I have set it
up on my Windows machine plus when you
use Google console you have a GUI which
I'll show you in couple of minutes and
also a cloud shell where you can use
your command line options to work with
Google Cloud platform you have Cloud
console which is nothing but your GUI to
access your resources now you can also
look at in-depth tutorials pricing and
you have different other options so
let's just click on pricing here and
then we have your price list which
basically gives you details of different
services what are available and what are
the services or what are the prices so
for example if I click on compute engine
right and this shows me the pricing
aspect of compute engine which belongs
to compute domain and here you can see
you have VM instance pricing you have
networking pricing Soul tenant nodes
which are specific to particular
organizations or if organizations would
want to have dedicated nodes you have
GPU based pricing right so General
processing units you have disk and image
pricing and you can click on any of the
links and you can see pricing which also
shows you your different kind of machine
types so here you have different kind of
machine types which says N1 N2 n2d E2
you have memory optimized machine types
you have compute optimized you have
premium images and you can basically
look at all the categories you can look
at disk pricing which involves your
persistent disk pricing for ssds or sdds
what are the kind of images what are the
different network Services right and you
can always look at your machine types
you can choose a particular region right
there is the concept of region and
availability zones here and as per
region you could look at the prices
you can also look at standard prices you
could be looking for what are the free
tier machines if I'm specifically
looking for VM instance pricing I can
click on this one and that takes me to
the VM instance pricing what is the
billing module what is the instance
uptime what is the resource base pricing
and then you can also look at different
kind of discounts such as sustained use
discounts committed use discounts
discounts from preemptable VM instances
and so on and this is how you can be
looking at pricing for all different
resources and you can choose the
resource which you are interested in and
then look for the pricing benchmarks
reservations if you would want to use
and you would want to benefit if you
would want to look at what are the
quotas and limits and so on so please
explore this link and you can find lot
of information when it comes to
technical options looking at different
Google Cloud products which we briefly
discussed when it comes to domains and
what each product can be used for you
can always come back to the main page
where I was showing you different
Services we went into pricing straight
away right now you can always come back
to this page on your cloud.google.com
and then you have your Solutions
which talks about different products
right and you can click on these or you
can look into technical documentation so
this talks about your different featured
Solutions infrastructure Solutions you
have data center migration related and
so on so I could be talking more and
more about Google Cloud platform it's a
ocean it's a huge chunk of different
services for different organizational
requirements so look into this link and
also what you can do is create a account
on Gmail I mean you could create a free
account or you could go to
cloud.google.com and then you could
create a free account like I have
created here and I can just click on
Console now that's my GUI or Google
Cloud console which basically allows me
to work with Google Cloud now there are
a lot of options here by default when
you create an account now in my case on
the top it says it's a free trial
account I have three hundred dollars
credit and out of that 251 dollars is
left and 237 days out of a year are left
for my account now here I can basically
see the project right and by default we
can create an project or by default
there is a project existing for any user
so when you log in it creates a
particular project and you could create
a new project and project would be to
dedicate your different services or
different resources per different
project so this is your dashboard which
basically shows your project which shows
you a project number and a project ID
which is always unique now you can click
on this and this if you would want you
can hide this information you can also
look into the documentation part of it
then it shows you the different services
or a graphical information of services
which you might have used in past so you
have compute engine which shows you how
how much percentage of CPU was used you
can always go to compute engine as a
service you can look at your Google
route platform status and look at the
Google Cloud status now this is billing
now since this shows me the billing
period for April month and I can always
look at detailed charges I can look at
reporting I can look at different apis
which Google offers and for your
different kind of work you can always go
to the API overview or the API link and
enable or disable any API now once you
enable or disable any API then you can
use that so you have new section you
have documentation and you have getting
started guides which tells you how to
work or enable different apis if you
would want to deploy a pre-built
solution at Dynamic logging monitoring
errors deploying a Hello World app and
so on now this is your dashboard I can
click on activity and that that would
show me what kind of activity I would
have done in my cloud platform I can
always choose the kind of activities by
saying activity type I can choose the
resources now it shows me that I created
some VM instances I deleted them I
updated some metadata I basically worked
on instances I changed some firewall
rules here I have then also worked on
some other services or apis so I created
some buckets which is for object storage
and again I have been working with some
instances and creating some firewall
rules here I have granted some
permissions I am setting up a policy
right so this activity gives me a
history of what things I have done over
past couple of months while working on
Google Cloud platform now
on the top left corner you have the
hamburger menu which you can click on
this so that's your navigation menu and
when you click on this this shows you
home it takes you to the marketplace it
specifically takes you to billing you
can always look at apis and services so
here in API Services I can pretty much
go to a dashboard and I can see a report
on the traffic or errors or latency and
the kind of apis which are available so
you have compute engine API you have
bigquery API bigquery data transfer API
bigquery storage cloud data proc so
these are some of the apis or Services
I've used in past might be I was
evaluating a product might be I was
using a particular product so you have
whenever you would want to use a
particular service from Google Cloud
platform you would be enabling these
apis so here we see some apis for data
proc you have logging monitoring you
have have resource manager API you have
Cloud SQL which allows you to directly
use MySQL or postgres you have cloud
storage right and so many apis so if I
would want to enable a particular API
which is not right now required but then
it's good to know you can always click
on this one you can search for an API so
for example if I would say data proc
right and that shows me the cloud data
proc API which manages Hadoop based
clusters and jobs on Google Cloud
platform so I can spin up a Hadoop
cluster and I can start running some
jobs on a Hadoop cluster on demand and
as I'm done with it I can just get rid
of it so this is an API which I would
have to enable and then for every
particular service you also have an
admin API which you would enable
now going back so coming out from this
API Library I got into API and services
now there is you can look into the
library you can look at credentials and
you can also look at different time
intervals for which you can see the
usage of your different apis now going
back to the menu you have support
wherein you can always reach out to the
Google support team if you are using a
paid version even with free trial you
can try to reach out and you will find
someone to help but it is always good
when you have a billing cycle reaching
out the customer care you have identity
access management and admin and this is
required when you're working with
different apis or Services when you
would want to have relevant access you
have getting started you have security
related options you have anthos which is
mainly for migration now here you can
look at your different domains such as
which we discussed so you have of
compute and in compute you have
different services so you have app
engine you have compute engine
kubernetes you have Cloud functions and
Cloud run you can look into the storage
aspect which shows you bit table which
is usually and mainly for your
unstructured data big table which is
something which gave rise to popular
nosql databases like edgebase and
Cassandra you have data store which can
be used you have firestore file store
storage which can be used to put in data
of any kinds you have SQL for structured
data you have spanner as a service you
have memory store and you have data
transfer now when it comes to the
networking domain you have all these
services such as VPC virtual private
network network related services for
your load balancing for using a
cloud-based DNS or Cloud defined Network
you have hybrid connectivity network
service TS security and and intelligence
then you have other options for your
operations which can be used and here
you have different other tools which can
be used such as Cloud build you have
Cloud tasks containers registry
deployment manager and many more big
data specific you have the services here
so you have data proc which can be used
to spin up your clusters you have
published subscribed messaging systems
such as now Kafka which you might have
heard of originates its idea from here
so Pub sub you have data flow you have
iot core bigquery which is a data
warehouse package or data warehousing
solution from Google Cloud now then you
have your artificial intelligence
related services and other Google
Solutions so you can always find a huge
list of services or you can say at high
level Solutions offered by Google cloud
and we can use these to basically test
some of the solutions use them and work
on them so I'll give you a quick demo on
different Services which can be used
here from your Google Cloud platform now
this is your Google Cloud platform and
this is your console now this also gives
you a cloud shell which can be activated
so that you can work from command line
and you can always find a lot of
documentation on that so you can also
set up your Cloud shell that is SDK on
your Windows machine and if you have set
it up then basically you could be doing
something like gcloud right if the cloud
has been set up so in my case I had set
up the cloud SDK and basically I can get
into that by looking at what path I have
set up so Cloud SDK and then I can be
using it from my Windows machine as per
my comfort I can also activate the cloud
shell here which will basically open up
a terminal and at any point of time you
can open up this one Cloud cell in a
different window it is preparing the
cloud shell where it will by default set
up your project it will set up the
metadata and now I am logged into my
Google Cloud account from command line
and here I can basically use gcloud
right and that basically shows you the
different options which are available
which you can be using so if you would
want to use a particular service you can
also try giving a help and that shows
you how do you manage your Google Cloud
platform right so you have different
options for billing to work with your
different services and basically you
could be working on Google Cloud using
this Cloud shell from your command line
usually for people who are learning old
cloud in the beginning it is always good
to go for console and use your different
services from here in an easier way but
as I said you can always use the command
line for example if I would just go
ahead and type gcloud create instances
and that will directly take me to the
cloud console documentation which shows
you different options which you can use
to work with instances so I could do a
gcloud compute instances create and then
I can give my instance name and so on
and I'll show you some examples on that
so you can be using your Cloud console
right that is your Cloud shell and you
can straight away start working from
command line however I would suggest
using console in the beginning and when
you are well experienced then you can
start using Cloud cell to do things from
command line and when you are fully
experienced you can always switch and
certain things are usually useful or
easier when done from command line and
some are easier when you do it from the
console and you can use any one of these
options now we can go to Google Cloud
console now as of now I can close this
one I still have my cloud cell open if I
would want to look into it I can click
on this one and I can straight away go
to compute end region where I would want
to work on creating some instances on
Google Cloud platform using the compute
engine service and then basically
connecting to those instances and
basically trying out some basic things
so you can click on VM instances and
then once this comes up I can always
create some instances now if you see
here I have some instances already
created right and I can continue working
on those I can create new instances I
can use different options while creating
instances and I'll show you that in a
demo in quick seconds so let's have a
quick demo on setting up gcp instances
now before that let's have a quick recap
so when you talk about instance or a
virtual machine it is hosted on Google's
infrastructure right and you can create
your Google Cloud instance using this
Google Cloud console that is by clicking
on this and then going to compute engine
and clicking on VM instances now you can
also do that from Google Cloud command
line tool that is cloud shell and you
can be doing that using compute engine
API so compute engine instances can run
the public images for Linux or Windows
servers that Google provides you also
have option of creating or using custom
images that you can create and import
from your existing systems you can
deploy Docker containers which are
automatically launched on instance
running containers optimized OS now when
you talk about instances and projects
always remember that in each instance
belongs to a Google Cloud console
project and a project can have one or
more instances
when you talk about instances and
storage options each instance has a
small boot persistent disk which I will
show you in for this queens that
contains the OS you can add more storage
space if needed and when you talk about
instances and network a project can have
up to five VPC networks so VPC network
is virtual private networks wherein you
can virtual private Cloud networks where
you can have your resources within your
own subnet and each instance belongs to
one VPC Network
now instances in same network can
communicate with each other through
local area network protocol an instance
uses internet to communicate within any
machine so that could be virtual
physical or outside its own network when
you talk about instances and containers
you should remember that compute engine
instances support a declarative method
for launching your application using
containers
now you can create a VM instance or a VM
instance template you can provide a
Docker image and launch the
configuration
so there are different ways in which you
can create these instances and once you
create these instances you can say for
example you're creating a Linux instance
you can associate SSH keys with your
Google account or your G Suite account
and then manage your admin non-admin
access to the instance using IM roles if
you connect to your instance using
gcloud or SSH from console which we will
see later compute engine can generate
SSH keys for you and apply that to your
Google cloud or G Suite account now what
we can do is we can see how we can
create your Google Cloud instances from
your console or from the command line
let's have a look in creating instances
using GCB console now that we have
learned on some basics of Google Cloud
platform what are the different Services
what are different domains basically
looking at your Google Cloud console or
even Cloud Shell let's go ahead and
create some VM instances now that's from
your compute engine service and let's
try connecting to these instances and
see how this works let's also see what
are the different options which are
available when you would want to create
the virtual machine instances here so
when you click on your drop down from
the top left and choose compute engine
so it brings you to this page so I can
show that again so you can click on
compute engine click on VM instances and
that basically brings you to this page
now here it tells you compute engine
lets you use Virtual machines that run
on Google's infrastructure so we can
create micro VMS or large instances
running different distributions of Linux
or Windows using standard images that is
public images and you can also have your
own image so let's create a VM instance
by clicking on create
now that's basically helping me to
create an instance here so it shows me
the instance name I can give it
something so let me say C1 now I can add
labels so what is label it basically
allows you to organize your project add
arbitrary labels as key value pairs to
your resources this so this is basically
categorizing your labels and projects if
you have multiple projects now remember
if you have your Cloud console and if
you have created your free trial account
it will allow you to do these things if
not you may have to go back to the
billing section and see if the billing
is enabled which also means that when
you are creating your Google Cloud
account it will ask you to clean your
credit card details but they do not
charge anything or they might charge
might be one dollar or one rupee
depending on your location and that's
also refunded but that's just to verify
your card now once I've given the name I
can choose a region so I would basically
choose Europe since I'm in Europe I
would be clicking on Europe West 3 and
here I can choose an availability Zone
availability zone is basically to make
your services or instances or any other
resources highly available so you can
choose one of the availability zones now
I would choose save S3 now this one we
can scroll down and here it says machine
configurations you have general purpose
machines you have memory optimized
machines which is M1 series and you can
always go back to the Google Cloud page
and see what a particular kind of
machine specializes in so I would click
on General's purpose and in general
purpose you have different categories so
you have N1 which is powered by Intel
Skylake CPU platform or you have E2
which is CPU platform selected selection
based on availability so let's have N1
selected now this one shows me the
machine type and if you are using your
free tier account then you can start
with correcting a micro machine which is
one virtual CPU core you can go for a G1
small which is one virtual CPU code and
1.7 GB Ram you can even go up to a
high-end machine and then you can
basically see if you are using a free
account how many of these machines you
can use if I would be selecting eight
virtual CPU cores and 32 gigabyte of
memory then it would allow me to create
at least two instances by this
configuration we will use N1 standard
which is one virtual CPU core 3.75 GB
memory now then we can also deploy a
container image to this VM instance if
you would be interested in deploying a
container image let's not get into that
right now here it shows you the port
disk and it shows you dbn gnu9 the next
nine what I would do is I can go for
this distribution or I can choose a
Linux distribution of my choice so here
you have public images you have custom
images you also have snapshots if you
have created backup of your previous
images here I can choose for example
Ubuntu and then I can choose a
particular version so let's go for
Ubuntu 18.04 you can go for the latest
one also 18.04 would be good enough and
here it tells me what is a boot disk so
you have ssds or you have standard
persistent disks now ssds are little
expensive in comparison to your standard
persistent disks or your sdds but then
ssds are faster so as of now we can
choose standard persistent disk as it is
and we can let the gigabyte be 10 now
depending on your requirement you can
increase this you can even add disks
later that's not a problem click on
select now here I have access Scopes so
here I will say allow default access you
can also set access for each API or you
can give full access to all Cloud apis
so that based on your requirement you
can any time change later also we will
also say allow HTTP traffic and we can
also choose allow https traffic that
basically allows me to access this
machine or Services which are HTTP based
accessible from this machine now I can
just click on create however it would be
good to basically enable connectivity to
this machine now we can do that in
different ways one is when you bring up
your machine it will have an SSH access
which you can log in from the cloud
platform here itself or what you can do
is you can create a private and a public
key using some softwares like putty or
puttygen so for example if you do not
have that on your machine you can
download you can just type in download
putty that takes you to the putty.org
page and here you can click on download
putty and scroll down which shows you
for your 64-bit machine which I have in
my case you can download putty.exe which
is basically your SSH internet client to
connect to your machines you can also
use putty gen which will be allowing you
to create a private and a public key
which I have done in my case let me show
you how so what you can do is you can go
to puttygen to begin with and here you
can click on generate now then to have
this key generated just move your cursor
on the top here in the empty space and
that creates your key you can give it a
name so for example let's give a
username I would give hdu now I can give
a password for this one so let me give a
simple password
and what I can also do is I can copy
this public key from here and for my
later usage I can just keep it in my
notepad file which I can use later and
I'll show you when so now we can save
this private key and this will basically
allow me to save my private key I can
choose desktop and I can give it a name
so let's say new key new key and that
will be getting saved in a DOT PPK file
so let's save it and that's done so we
also have our public key and we have
saved our private key now we know that
when you would want to connect using SSH
you need your private keys to the client
and public key also has to be existing
so let's take this public key so let's
do a control a I'm going to copy this
and I'm going to come back to my Google
Cloud console and here you can click on
security so you can click on the
security tab here here scroll down and
just give your public key once you give
that it resolves and shows you the name
and this is good enough so that I can
use my SSH client to connect to this
machine I can click on Create and this
will basically create my VM instance it
will take some time and then your
instance will have an internal IP which
will show up here external IP and it
will also show you options to connect to
these machines so this is my internal IP
this is my external IB which I can use
to connect from a client I can easily
connect from the option here which says
SSH and I can say open in a browser
window I can even open this in a custom
Port I can look at the gcloud command
which you can give from cloud shell or
you can use another SSH so let's first
do a open in browser window and let's
see if this connects so we can easily
connect to our instance the Ubuntu 18
instance which I just set up here easily
in couple of seconds now this is trying
to establish a connection using your SSH
keys and when you do that it also
basically brings up this web browser so
I'm already connected it shows my
username which is my cloud account
username and I have been connected to
this machine here using SSH it did not
ask me for any password and basically
now I can just check what do I have in
my Linux file system right and I can
anytime login as root by doing a sudo Su
for example let's try installing a
package and I can say appkit install
whim or app get install wget or aptkit
install open SSH and all these packages
are already existing so not an issue now
I can start using this instance I can
just look at the disk what is available
okay now we gave an 10 gigabyte out of
which we see 8.3 gigabyte here for the
dev sda1 and then 1.8 gigabyte available
and you can continue using this machine
this was the easiest way of connecting
to a VM instance using SSH
now what we can also do is I can just
leave this and I will now try to connect
using an external SSH client right and
here you can copy the public IP so when
you want to connect to an instance you
will have to get the public IP also
remember that if you select and stop
this machine which will stop your
billing counter and if you start it
again the internal IP will remain same
but the external IP is the one which
will change
I can obviously select this machine
anytime and I can do a cleanup and I can
delete it I can do a start of the
machine if it is stopped and I can even
import the virtual machine to be used
later so there are different options
which you can always use so this is my
instance and if you would want to look
at the details click on this one C1 and
that should basically allow you to look
at the details so it shows you what is
the instance ID what is the machine type
is it reservation specific what is the
CPU platform what's the zone and all the
other details
at any point of time if you would want
to edit you can always click on edit and
you can change the details as you need
now you can also look at the equivalent
rest command to basically use the rest
API to connect to this instance for now
I have copied the public IP and I would
want to connect it using putty so let's
go in here and let's give the host name
so I can give Ubuntu I can give my IP
address so that's in my session now I
will click on SSH I would go into
authentication I'll click on browse and
this is where I need to choose the PPK
file so this is the one which we created
new key let's select this
and then I can come back to session I
can even save this and I can call it as
my instance one let's save it and you
can create any number of instances so
you see I have created different
instances here for my Google cloud or
Amazon related instances and I can click
on open it says the service host key is
not cached in the registry that's fine
just click on yes
and basically it says no authentication
method supported now this could be
because we have not enabled your SSH
access so let's look at that so now
let's see if we were trying to connect
using putty what was the issue here so
if I go back to my putty select my
instance load it it says Port 22 I am
giving the username which is Ubuntu or
sorry that's the wrong username we gave
and that might be the reason we had set
up the user as sdu so let's save this
again and now let's try connecting to
this one and it asks for my password and
you are able to connect this right now
if there was any other issue related to
network connectivity then we could look
at the rules the inbound and outbound
rules which allow us to look into the
machine now we are connected to our
machine here using hdu user I can log in
as root and I can continue working so
not only from the SSH within the cloud
console but you can use an external SSH
client and connect to your machine so
this is your Ubuntu machine and we can
basically look at the space and that
basically confirms we are connecting to
the same machine which shows 8.3
gigabytes here and 1.8 gigabytes here
which we were seeing from the ssh in the
browser now let's close this and let's
go back to our instance page now here
you can always look at the network
details and this will show you your
different kind of rules that is ingress
or egress rules which basically allows
to connect to this machine from an
external network or for this machine to
connect to an external network so here
we have different firewall rules which
shows default allow HTTP that's your
Ingress Rule and it tells you apply to
all it shows me what are the IP ranges
where I can specifically give the ipf my
machine it shows the protocols it shows
what are the different ports which you
have used for these services for example
RDP or SSH which shows 22 you have icmp
HTTP and https now anytime if you would
want to make a change to these rules
that can be done by going into your
network details and say for example you
would want to work on firewall rules so
we have these firewall rules here you
can click on this one so right now we
are looking into the network domain and
we are looking into VPC Network right
and this shows me what are the different
rules we have now if I would want to
create a different firewall rule for a
different protocol I can always click on
create firewall rule I can give it a
name okay I can say what if you would
want to turn on the firewall logs you
can basically say what is the kind of
traffic so Ingress applies to incoming
traffic and egress applies to outgoing
traffic and you can then basically
choose what are the IP ranges from where
you want that connection to be coming in
or to going out you can choose a
particular protocol you can give a
protocol here with comma separated
values and you can create a firewall
rule so this might be required depending
on the services which you are running
wherein you might want to enable in your
access to your machine from an external
service or to an external service so you
can always go to network details from
here you can then go into firewall rules
create a firewall rule apply that to
your instance and restart your instance
so as of now we don't need to create any
network details here because my Ingress
or egress rules are already available
right now I can basically then have my
instance stopped and removed so I can
just do a stop or since this is running
the ideal wave would be to do a stop I
could also do a reset now what does
reset do reset does not basically delete
the machine what it does is it does a
cleanup of the machine and it brings it
to the initial state so sometimes we
might have installed certain things on
our machine we would want to clean them
up and at that time reset can be useful
I can basically click on delete right
and I can select this and I can underway
cleanup and this is good always when you
are using a free trial account try to
use different Services play around with
them and then you can clean up so that
you do not waste your free billing
credit right and you can use it for
Meaningful stuff now I have clicked on
delete and within few seconds my
instance which I had created will be
deleted also to remember is if you are
creating multiple instances then you can
connect from one machine to other
machine using SSH by using the private
file so for that we can learn in detail
later so this is just a simple example
of using your compute engine creating
your instances connecting to it from an
internal SSH or from an external SSH
client such as putty where you have
already created your private and public
Keys now I can click on the browser here
and then I can basically come out and I
can basically looking into any
particular service so we just looked
into compute engine right you have
different other options you have
instance groups you have instance
templates for example let's click on
instance templates here and that
basically shows you that you don't have
any instance template and this basically
facilitates say for example you are
working as a admin and you would want to
create an instance template so that
using that you can describe a VM
instance and then you can basically use
this template to create different
instances you can go for soul tenant
nodes you can look for machine images
you can also look at your disks you can
create a snapshots and you can look at
different options here now let's come
back here and let's click on home and
that should take you back to your home
page which basically shows you if a
particular API which you have used
recently which shows me in the graph
here so I can go to the api's overview
right and that basically shows me if
there were any errors if I was using the
compute engine API to basically create a
VM instance and that's why we were
seeing some spike in the graph so this
is a quick demo of using your compute
engine service provided by Google Cloud
wherein you can create VM instances and
use those VM instances for your
application installation for any other
purpose now that we have seen how you
use your Cloud console to create an
instance and also clean it up let's also
understand how you can do using your
command line options and let's see what
it takes or what are the different
commands which you can use to create
your instances
now you can always when when you're
creating an instance you can use compute
engine which Provisions resources to
start the instance so instance basically
has different states which we can see
when we are creating the instance so you
basically start the instance instance
moves into staging that is prepared for
your first boot finally it boots up and
then it moves into running so when you
look at instant states which we will
create instance in C it will basically
have different states such as
provisioning where resources are being
allocated for instance but instances not
yet running then it goes into staging
where resources have been acquired and
instance is being prepared for your
first boot then instance is booting up
and running and if you are stopping an
instance it goes into being stop status
and it would be moved to the terminated
option you can also do a repairing of
instance and finally you can terminate
your instance or clean it up by stopping
and then deleting it now when you say
stopping and resetting an instance you
can stop the instance as I showed
earlier if you no longer need it but if
you need for future use you can just use
the reset option which will basically
wipe the content tense of instance or
any application State and then finally
you can stop it and have it terminated
now when you would want to do that using
your Cloud console or we have seen the
options now let's also see from the
command line tool how you can do it so
here I have the cloud cell which I
brought up from here and I basically
opened it in a new window so command
line tool enables you to easily manage
your compute engine resources in a
friendlier format than using your
compute engine API now gcloud which is
part of cloud SDK is the main command
here and then you can always auto
complete the different options here so
when you would want to create or work on
gcloud you can just type in gcloud here
and then for example I could just say
help to see different options of gcloud
which will show me the different options
which you can use here now we would be
interested in compute instances so I
could also do a gcloud compute
compute instances and then I can
basically say create and then I can do a
help now that should show me different
options which work with gcloud compute
instances create command which is
expecting an instance name
so your Google Cloud SDK which we can
set up on our Windows machine or even on
your Linux machine a set of tools that
helps you to manage resources and
applications hosted on your gcp that is
your Google Cloud platform now here you
have options such as gcloud which I am
showing you right now you have Gs util
and then you have BQ so that also can be
used so you can set up a Google Cloud
compute if using gcloud now what we can
do is if we are setting up our SDK on
our Windows machine then we would have
to do a gcloud init which basically
initializes your configurations for GE
cloud
now here we are using a cloud shell
which was started from the console and
we don't have to basically give your
gcloud init command because it's already
initialized now you can always look at
your default Zone you can look at your
region what is being used all those
things are coming from the metadata
which is being used so for example I
could be looking at the metadata for my
particular project by just doing a g
cloud and then I can say compute and I
would be interested in Project info so I
can just do a project minus info and
then I can do it describe and then I
need my project ID so I can say minus
minus project and I can get my project
ID from here so you can click on this
one and that's my project ID so I can
click click on this one and here I can
just do a right click and if it does not
paste then you can do a control V and
then I can try to look at my project
info so this basically will give me the
metadata which is by default set and we
can always look at what are the regions
or what is the Zone which has been set
so if it has been set so I'm looking at
my details it is showing me my SSH keys
and then it can be using your default
region and your default available zones
it also shows my username and other
details so this is basically to look at
the metadata which is available now at
any point of time I can basically say
add metadata I can basically choose
metadata option and I can say my default
region should be Europe which I was
choosing earlier so I can just bring up
this command again and what I can do is
I can say here where I have gcloud
compute project info where I did a
describe earlier now what I could also
do is I can just say add metadata
and then I can specify what is the
metadata I would be interested in adding
I can then say Google compute
default
region and then I can basically give a
region for example Europe and then I can
say West 3
and if you are not well experienced you
can always do it from console or you can
be doing it from here so I'm giving
Google Cloud compute Google compute
default region then I can also give a
Google compute default Zone
and then I can pass in a value for
default zone so I can say Europe West 3
and then basically I can give an
availability zone so if it is basically
giving me some error where I'm trying to
pass in these values so I can just give
it this way and then it basically says
that if you can look into particular
help to see what is the command which
you would have to do now I can basically
do a g Cloud init here initial
configuration and this basically says
that it is initializing my default
configuration it says re-initialize this
configuration from cloud shell you want
to create a new configuration so if I
had updated my metadata then basically I
could just do a cloud in it and I could
be re-initializing my default
configuration or properties which I have
passed constant so as of now I will not
activate or change the default region
let's go for a simple way in which you
can create your compute engine so for
example I'll just say one and it is
reinitializing it asks me what is the
username and let's select that it says
what is the project and let's select
that and do you want to configure a
default compute region and zone right
and I will just say Yes And basically
then it shows me different options which
we have here so there are too many
options here and then here we were
interested in Europe West 3 so let's
choose 21 right and then that basically
allows me to choose my region and my
zone so it also gives you some
specification so it says your project
default compute Zone has been set to
Europe West 3A you can change it by
running gcloud config set and you can
give a compute zone right so I can
always give these commands I can get
help information here so I can just say
gcloud config set and I can be
specifying the compute zone so I can say
compute slash Zone and I can give a Zone
I can say compute slash region and I can
give a region name if I would want to do
it or the easier ways like what I did
right now so you can basically do a
command gcloud in it and then basically
it allows you to to change your
configuration or set default things here
you can all the times you can say gcloud
config unset to basically remove a
compute zone or a compute region now
there are different ways so if you were
working on a Linux machine you could
always use an export command something
like this so you could do export compute
sorry Cloud
SDK and then you can say compute
underscore Zone and then give your Zone
name or compute underscore region and
give your region or you could add it in
your bash RC file right now that is when
you have your Cloud SDK set up on your
Linux machine or on Windows machine and
you would want to specifically set a
Zone and a region for all your compute
related resources so we don't need to do
that the default settings are already
given here right and what we can do is
we can start by quickly looking into
gcloud compute instances options so I
can say gcloud compute instances and
then I can just do a list at any point
of time if you would need help you can
just do a gcloud compute and then say
minus minus help or I could just do a
gcloud compute and that shows me
different options which I have here from
which I use instances I can always type
instances and again hit enter and it
shows me different options what you
would want to do so I can initially just
type list which should show me what are
the list or what are the instances
available and as of now we don't have
any instances I can always do a list and
then I can specify minus minus format
and then try to get the information in a
Json format or EML or minus minus format
text
so you can always do a list you can do a
filter so there are different options
with your list and you can you can try
doing a help here and that basically
shows you what are the options so for
example if I do a help and it shows me
with list what are the things you can do
so you can give a name you can give a
regular expression you can say in
particular Zone you can use a minus
filter so there are different commands
which are available and you can always
find all those options here as I showed
you earlier so now what we would be
interested in is basically going for
your compute instances I can always do a
SSH and I can create an instance I can
add and remove metadata right for my
instances by giving a particular Zone by
giving a particular region and if you
would want to do that now here what we
can do is we can can basically create an
instance by just giving a name to that
particular instance and we can then go
back to our console and see what has it
done so I can say here create so that's
an option let's see what does the create
do so it says okay you are giving a
create option but you would have to give
a name so let's say let's call it E1 and
that will be the name of my instance and
this one is an easy command from your
Cloud cell which basically creates an
instance you see the Zone which has been
set it is the standard machine type it
is not preemptable it has an internal IP
and it has an external IP now I have
created an instance and here I can just
go back and then I can just do a Refresh
on this page and that already shows me
the instance which I've created and then
you can use the same method to connect
to it using an SSH so I have an instance
created from my cloud shell and what I
can do is I can basically look into
instances and see what are the different
options with instance so if we did a
create right you have an option delete
we did a create you have an option
delete you can be and deleting the
instance from the command line or you
can use other options so you can do a
list you can do a stop you can start so
I can basically do a stop and let's say
even let's go ahead and do a stop
commands are pretty easy here to
remember or you can always use the help
option and now I'm trying to stop the
instance and then basically I can go
ahead and delete it so this is a simple
way where I created a instance from the
command line or from the console which I
showed earlier and similarly you can be
working with other options so now I have
created stop the instance let's do a
listing to see if my instance shows up
it shows up right and it says the status
is terminated so you have stopped it
it's in the terminated status and now
what I can do is I can go ahead and
delete it
so it says this will be lost are you
sure you would want to continue just say
yes and that should take care of
deleting your instance
so this is a quick demo on creating your
instance we have already seen how you
can connect to these instances using SSH
now that we have created instances let's
also see how to use Google Cloud's
storage service which can be used to
load data or upload data so for this we
will have to look into your Google cloud
storage options and here you can look in
cloud storage so let's go back here on
the top which shows me different
Services which we have here and let's
look into storage so this one shows me
your storage option now you can click on
browser and that basically shows me your
storage browser which shows me on the
top you have options for creating a
bucket now Google Cloud Storage allows
you to store any kind of data here the
easiest and the simplest way would be by
using Cloud console although you can
again use cloud shell and in that you
can use your GS util command and GS util
basically has different options where
you can be using say for example I would
want to work on buckets so I can be
using MB and then I can use my command
line option to create buckets I can put
in data there I can browse it and I can
access the data from command line so
let's create a bucket here let's click
on this let's give it a name so let's
say my data important that's the name
now I can click on continue straight
away I can look into all of these
options if I'm interested in so you can
basically be looking at your monthly
cost estimate in the beginning now I can
click on continue or you can say choose
where to store your data and this one
shows you different options so you have
region specific like
so let's also give the bucket name with
all lower case that's what is required
yeah so coming back to the location type
you can choose multi-region which
basically allows High availability so
your bucket or your storage option will
be accessible across regions you can
also give dual region and high
availability and low latency across two
regions I can also say region specific
so for our use case we can just keep
region specific which can keep our cost
low but in business use cases you would
be going for multi-region now here you
have location and I would again go for
say Europe and let's choose Europe West
3 Frankfurt it is always a good practice
that when you create your instances when
you create your storage or you use
different Services try to have a
geographical region Chosen and then you
would try to put things on your services
within the particular region within a
particular Zone unless you would want to
make it accessible and available across
regions
now I can then choose a default storage
class so when you say default storage
class there are different storage class
and each one is for a different use case
so you have standard which is best for
short-term storage and frequently
accessed data you have near line so this
is basically best for backups and data
access less than once a month you can
also have code lines so these are
basically like your cold storage or
freezing storage which you might have
heard generically as terms so you can
choose one of these storage classes
depending on what will be the use case
for this particular storage bucket so
let it be standard now how to control
access to objects so you can basically
say specify access to individual objects
by using object level permissions now
you can give permissions to the bucket
you can just say uniform access to all
objects in the bucket by using only
Bucket Level permissions so you can
choose that you can also go into
advanced settings and here you can see
different ways in which you can have
configuration set up now you can also
have a retention policy to specify the
minimum duration where that this
bucket's object must be protected from
deletion and you can set a retention
policy will not get into all that we
will just first try creating a bucket so
just click on Create and that should
create your bucket wherein I have my
bucket now I can click on overview to
see the details what is the region which
region it belongs what is the storage
class anytime you can always click on
edit bucket and make some changes here
you can look at the permissions so
bucket uses fine grained access allowing
you to specify access to individual
objects and then you can basically look
at who has access to this so in my case
editors of the project they basically
are the bucket owners owners of project
viewers of the project right and you can
basically choose what kind of access you
need so for this you can always go into
cloud storage and then you can decide
what kind of access you would want to
give whether that's a storage admin it's
an object admin object Creator object
viewer and so on you can always look at
storage Legacy
and for any other services depending on
what apis you have enabled right you can
always control your permissions so right
now it is storage Legacy bucket reader
and that's fine and this one is bucket
owner and then might be I was using some
other services like data proc which uses
cloud storage and that's why I have
given data's proc service agent also so
these are some of the members you can
remove you can view by specific members
you can view by roles so what are the
different roles which have access to
this so it says storage Legacy bucket
owner there are two owners based on this
particular project so these are Auto
controlled but then you can add or
remove machines you can save storage
cost by adding a life cycle rule to
delete objects after the duration of
current retention policy so you can add
different policies and you can basically
control your bucket now my bucket is
already created right so so I can go
back and then I see my bucket is already
here I can click on this option and you
can anytime edit the bucket permissions
you can edit the labels the default
storage class you can just go ahead and
delete the bucket you can export it to
Cloud Pub sub so basically if you would
want to have the content from this
bucket being accessible in a message
queuing system you can go for Pub sub
you can process with Cloud functions and
you can scan with cloud data loss
prevention so there are different
options which are available we can
always select this bucket and delete it
now I can click on the bucket and that
basically shows me different ways in
which I can upload some data here so I
can just click on upload files and here
then I can choose some files so for
example I'll go in here I'll go into
data sets and I have different data sets
so for example let's choose this one
which is a CSV file and then I'm just
uploading this to my storage right it's
as simple as this so you can drag and
drop your files or you can just upload
your files and my file is uploaded here
now I can basically edit permissions for
this one right so this is in the bucket
so anyone who has access to this bucket
can basically download this file it can
they can copy move or rename this you
can export it and you can look at the
permissions of this file so let's look
at edit permissions and it says
for this project whoever is the owner it
has access I have also given a specific
user my Gmail ID and I've given access
so at any point of time you can just say
add item and then you can start giving
different kind of accesses so let's
click on cancel here now my data is
already uploaded into this particular
bucket and that's a simple usage of your
cloud storage now what we can also do is
I can basically select this and I can
delete it I can also create specific
folders and then basically load data
into it I can click on this one I can
just do a download and then I can
download it anywhere on my machine so
let's go to desktop and let's download
this file so we not only uploaded some
content in the bucket but we also
downloaded that in a different location
which will be accessible now what I
could have also done is I could have
created a folder here and I could have
specified say for example immediate
immediate data
okay and I'm clicking on this one so
that's my immediate data I can click on
this one and now I can upload my data
specifically to this particular folder
by using the same mechanism you can just
do upload file let's choose air
passengers let's say open and my file
will be uploaded so you can always
choose what is the retention expiry date
for this one so as of now there is
nothing right but you can be deleted
objects can be deleted or modified until
there is a minimum duration you can
control all of that you can basically
download it right you can copy it and
you can move it and rename it so this is
a simple example where I created a
particular bucket right now if for
example you click on this transfer so it
says cloud storage data transfer
products have moved you can now find
storage transfer service on-premise data
and transfer Appliance in new data
transfer section right so you can always
go back
to cloud storage you can also look at
transfer options which are mainly when
you are using your on-premise service
and you would want to upload data in a
Google Cloud right so this is my bucket
here now I can go to Cloud console and
here what I can do is if I would be
interested in working so I can just say
GS util right and then we have for
example let's try a help okay and that
basically shows me my GS util now you
can always go to Quick Start gsutil tool
and this is one more way wherein
basically you can do it from the command
line so working with buckets so you can
do a GS util MB minus B and then on a
particular Zone if you would be
interested in and then you can say GS
colon and give a name so my awesome
bucket this is how you will create a
bucket which will show you it is
creating a bucket and then basically you
can upload an image or some data from
internet you can just do a w get
download the file and then you can just
do a GS util copy command and that
basically will pick up the file from
your Cloud shell location put it in your
bucket once you have done that you can
always do a copy right so here you are
doing a copy from your local machine
that is your Cloud cell machine to your
bucket and you can do the reverse of
that that is you can do a copy and you
can point your bucket and the file and
download it to your desktops so you can
just download that using the command
line and you can copy the object to a
folder in the bucket so that is by
creating a particular folder and you are
pushing the file into a particular
bucket you can list the contents of a
bucket using LS and then give your
bucket name so GS colon so we can just
try this one to be simple and rest you
guys can try so so here you can just do
a GS util you can do a LS GS colon slash
slash and then I need to give my bucket
name so in my case the bucket name was
my data important so let's try that so
let's save my data important and I'm
trying to list the bucket and the
content it has right and then you have a
folder and then you can look into the
folder and look into the files so this
is a simple quick option wherein you can
use your Cloud cell you could be using
your Google Cloud SDK from your local
machine or you can be using Cloud
console to create a bucket upload some
data on it download the data see if the
data is accessible and that basically
shows you the power of cloud storage
where you can easily upload any kind of
data now what we can also do is as you
are using a free account or even a paid
account unless and until you would want
to keep the bucket you can select it and
you can just go ahead and delete it so
this will basically ask you to key in
the bucket name and let's say my data
important you need to confirm your
bucket name click on confirm and you
could have done that using gsutil and a
delete command from the command line
that is from cloud cell so we have now
created a bucket we have uploaded some
data into it we saw how you can download
it or create a folder and upload some
specific data into it and also you can
do the same thing using GS util tools
wherein you can list your bucket create
your buckets delete it create some
folders into it and do everything from
the command line so this is in simple
way you can use your gcp where either
you can spin up your machines or you can
use cloud storage to basically use a
storage or a easy to use instance on if
you're ready to embark on a career path
buzzing with excitement Innovation and
boundless possibilities look no further
then simply learns Caltech postgraduate
program in cloud computing focusing on
gcp this comprehensive program equips
you with the knowledge and skills needed
to navigate the vast landscape of cloud
computing with unbeavering confidence
Unleash Your Potential as you delve into
the depths of gcp architecture conquer
deployment models fortify security like
an impedetrable Fortress and master
migration strategies that leave elastic
impact discover how to harness the full
suit of gcp services to construct not
just scalable applications but true
masterpieces of Technology don't let
this once in a lifetime opportunity slip
through your fingers ignite your career
and join the ranks of triumphant cloud
computing professionals click the link
in the description to uncover the
wonders of this course
hello and welcome to the Google Cloud
platform fundamentals course offered by
simply learn
this is lesson one introducing Google
Cloud platform
in this lesson we're going to take a
look at the very underpinnings of the
Google Cloud platform
what is today about today is an
introduction to the Google Cloud
platform and you may be coming from
another Cloud platform or you may be
just curious about what is cloud and in
particular what is Google's offering of
the cloud and this that is what this
course is all about
the the course will cover a lot of
material in terms of breadth and we will
not go into a lot of detail on the
particular items that's reserved for
some other courses so my objective for
you is to explain what the terms are
and what the abstractions are and then
we'll have some Labs where you can do
some additional exploring and get a feel
for things so you're going to hear about
the different parts of the cloud and
you'll experiment with some of them in
in some labs
what I have discovered and I've worked
in various clouds
is that even the terminology is not
settled
so it's one particular vendor may use a
word in a certain way and another vendor
may use it in a different way so one of
the things I hope that you will leave
with is an understanding of what Google
means when they say particular things
for example platform as a service or
infrastructure as a service
now we're going to take a brief look at
the overview of the Google Cloud
platform this will include a brief tour
of the hardware underpinnings
that they give to the various
abstractions including things like what
does it mean for a resource to be global
what does it mean for a resource to be
Regional and what does zonal mean
these abstractions live on top of the
hardware level and it's important to
understand that there is a distinct
difference between the two
so why choose a cloud platform to begin
with well it's one of the things that
Google mentioned recently in a
presentation they said that if you look
at the cost of a computer if you look at
over its four-year life
that the majority of the cost is energy
and Google is very very focused on
making their data centers very energy
efficient and they've invested a lot in
Security in extremely high speed
networking and I'm convinced that
companies and especially small companies
just can't match that investment so
there is a broad movement to the cloud
people are realizing that it's going to
be better to rent instead of buy
computers and if you look at the Google
Cloud platform they've had years and
years of experience building out a cloud
platform for their search for their
Gmail for their very you know YouTube
for their various offerings and they
decided a while ago that they wanted to
make this available to all of us so
they're offering this so that we can
build and test and deploy applications
on their platform that scale just as the
Google application scale
Computing solution there is no one ideal
way of storing information so Google
offers a lot of choices several choices
in Computing their choices in storage
they're options for Big Data one of the
things that Google is really leading on
now is machine learning so by opening
this up we can work on this highly
scaled Global compute infrastructure and
build our own applications that run
alongside of Google's apps
and as you know Google is in the
business for a long time so they've had
all that time to perfect their
technology
so
so there's a couple words here that I
want to Define so that we're all clear
a data center is a facility it's a
building or multiple buildings that have
their own power substations they have
high security there's perimeter fencing
there's all sorts of codes that you have
to use to get inside then very very few
people actually ever get inside a data
center it's highly secure and this is
where all the computers are this is
where the networking is this is where
you know the the low level compute power
of the cloud is is residing they have
different data centers and they're
opening many more we'll talk about that
a little bit later
another really critical thing about the
Google infrastructure is they have a
very well designed very well thought out
networking underneath all of this they
have a global meshed redundant fiber
optic Network that spans the globe and I
don't know you may have noticed in the
in the news recently that they announced
a connection with Asia a new one that
they've just put the fiber down so
they're actively building new
connections a point of presence is the
edge of Google and the rest of the
internet so if you're have a computer
and you need to have packets go to
Google they'll Transit from your
computer through the internet and
they'll hit a point of presence and
that's where your packets your
connection will get on the Google Fiber
and find its way into the Data Center
and they have over 110 Edge points of
presence now in 33 countries just a
little while ago it was I think 80. so
they're expanding those quite aggressive
and if you look at information flowing
out from the data centers to you or your
clients there's Edge caching so these
are also residing right at the edge of
the Google Fiber and they will cache
through your information to make it a
faster interaction with your customers
and we'll talk about caching a bit more
when we look at some of the particulars
of the compute infrastructure
this is actually one of the more
important slides of the whole session
this is the first one where we're going
above the physical so when the physical
we talked about actual computers data
centers the fiber cables the switches
the network cables and so on we're going
to leave those behind and now we're
going to raise ourselves in terms of
abstractions and the three terms that
are crucial are Global Regional and
zonal so these are essentially the
lowest level of idea that we're going to
be working with so let's start with Zone
and a zone is roughly equivalent to a
Data Center and zones are where you have
your compute power you have your disks
and so on in terms of Designing a system
especially for a high availability
system you need to consider that a Zone
could fail
so it's best to have compute power in
multiple zones and balance the request
across them and and we'll talk about
that particular detail later the
important thing to know is that some
resources in the cloud are anchored in a
zone for example a compute engine
instance is a zonal resource the next
abstraction is region and a region is a
geographic area and it may it will
contain multiple zones and an example of
a resource that's Regional is a network
load balancer so you can set up Network
load balancer and then it will send the
request two different zones and it will
be aware of the health of all the
computers so if one does fail it will
stop sending requests there and it'll
send it to other computers in different
zones and the third concept is global so
there are some resources that are Global
that span all the different regions for
example when you create a network it is
a global resource so your compute
engines in a Zone will come connect to a
network which is global and essentially
they can talk to any other computer
connect to that Global Network so you
can easily configure a system where
everything appears to be on a local area
network but in fact it's a Global
Network so and that points out another
thing that's kind of important about
moving to the cloud is some of the
things that you know based on your
experience with the real world you know
I say the real world the physical world
of computers and so on
some of those ideas you're going to need
to leave behind because it's different
some things are quite different when you
get into the cloud and I'll be sure to
point those out as we as we work through
these uh these slides
so again let's look at Cloud regions and
zones and global zonal resources operate
in a single zone an example again is a
compute engine instance and its
Associated disks a regional resources
are in a geographic area for example U.S
Central or Asia or Europe and a region
will have multiple zones and then Global
is spanning the whole planet so you may
want to have a single IP address for
your web application that would be a
global resource and Google provides load
balancers across regions and you can
have Regional load balancers that
balance things across zones
Google is really working hard to Pioneer
efficiency and performance in their data
centers they as I said that they have
determined that the majority of the cost
of computing is energy so they are
focused very very diligently on reducing
the cost they've been carbon neutral
since 2007 they're investing heavily in
wind and solar and they have been
they're pioneering efficiencies so
they're a really good engineering
company that's one of the things that
you need to keep in mind as you learn
about the various parts of the Google
Cloud platform they're good Engineers
they're very proud of their engineering
and they do incredible jobs with what
they're focused on recently they've
applied artificial intelligence to
optimize each Data Center for Energy use
so they will measure ambient temperature
and other factors and adjust all the
parameters for a particular data center
so it has it consumes the least amount
of energy possible
there's also a trend that we're very
very aware of and that is that the price
of computing is constantly going down
and Google is very focused also on
passing the savings along to us and
they've come up with several ways of
monetizing the savings one is sub-hour
billing so the idea here is that if you
ask for a computer I'll give you a
specific example you can ask for a 32
core 208 gigabyte computer and run it
for only 20 minutes you know they don't
round up to the next hour and the cost
for renting a computer of that size for
20 minutes maybe you're checking out
some code maybe you've got a caching
algorithm or something like that you
want to test well that will cost you
about 50 cents so it's really really
economical to use for experimentation
and getting things set up and and the so
and so on
on the other side once you get your
software stable and you're ready to
deploy it Google has what's called a
sustained use discount so as you use the
Computing infrastructure throughout the
month they will give you an increasing
discount that basically it goes up to
about 25 percent so the rewarding not
just
temporary use but they're also rewarding
sustained use there's another feature
they came out with which is custom
machine type so you can dial in exactly
the amount of CPU power and memory that
you need for your application and we're
hearing reports that that will save
customers about 10 or 15 percent and the
fourth Innovation they've come up with
is what's called preemptable instances
so these are this is like Scavenging the
for free essentially an unused compute
power so if you build a system that that
anticipates a computer going down and
your software can understand that and
reschedule it on another computer you
literally can save 50 percent the price
is half of the same machine in
non-preemptable mode
so again there's four ways that they are
currently providing uh they're passing
on the savings that they're finding from
declining prices of computers
Google has made numerous contributions
to cloud computing in fact they've been
pioneers of cloud computing since the
very beginning all of their major
products including search maps YouTube
and other features like that run on
their own cloud computing infrastructure
they've been running containers for
years and now they want to provide that
understanding that intellectual property
and the ability to scale applications to
Google scale to us
Google's well they're they're focused on
innovation
and what they have learned is that it's
it's to their benefit and it's to the
industry's benefit to make things open
and as they have designed Innovative
Technologies to support their own
infrastructure they have released
technical papers describing what they've
done so they've had names like Dremel
and Colossus and things like that and
once they've published these papers the
open source Community has noted them has
read them and frequently will implement
the ideas as an open source product
and the the Google has really taken note
of that and in fact they are releasing a
lot of their new Innovations completely
open source a notable example that we'll
look at later is something called
kubernetes so they've they've learned
how to run containers very efficiently
on their infrastructure and they decided
to rebuild all of that add some new
intellectual property and release that
as a open source project that we can all
join we can all use
uh open source licensing again that
follows with not just kubernetes but a
lot of the low-level libraries for
connecting to the Google Cloud platform
they release those open source and again
it helps everyone it helps Google and
moves the industry forward
the Publications I've mentioned already
for example you can look on papers on
how they've built their uh their
low-level data stores what Dremel is
about Dremel is about high efficiency
querying of data
and because of this interoperability and
the fact that they've released things
open source we can now think about even
building things across multiple
platforms multiple Cloud providers so
again kubernetes is the open source
container management software that
Google's released Google has a product
called container engine that uses
kubernetes and adds some special Google
features but you can run kubernetes on
your own machine you could run it on
Amazon you can run it on openstack you
could run it on digitalocean you can run
it anywhere and so by doing that Google
is opening up the interest of the whole
industry about containers and Google's
gamble I mean it is a gamble they're
they're releasing their key intellectual
property they believe that they will be
able to provide the best platform the
best product for running containers and
by reducing the risk to all of us by
having kubernetes be open source
everybody wins and Google will be in a
good position
Google is not standing still and this
slide is meant to show you a bit of
where their vision is going so the first
wave we've had is was co-location and I
literally on my desk have a computer
that I sent to a co-location place a
long time ago and I've since requested
it back so co-location is where you
either send your equipment and it's
located in a managed environment or you
rent computers that are in a managed
environment and you can imagine your
computer sitting in a rack and you can
connect to it and the advantage is that
you've got that vendor security and
you've got their power and so on
the next wave that happened is
virtualization so here we're getting
into virtual machines and we're starting
to get the virtualization of various
parts and this is essentially where we
are right now we're right at the end of
the second wave and we're moving into
the Third
and the third is a completely Global
elastic cloud and once we move here
we'll we'll not worry about virtual
machines we'll just ask for a bit of
compute power and we'll get it you know
and we'll probably get it very very
quickly so we'll be able to scale up
we'll be able to scale down and we'll be
able to match the compute resources that
we consume to match the the needs of our
software as requests go up and the
requests go down
the fact that you can have a Computing
environment that tracks with your usage
is is actually it's it's more
significant than you might think and
from a technical perspective it has huge
benefits from a business perspective
uh just think about how you have to in
the old days you'd have to invest in a
large number of servers if you had a
startup company and get your software
ready get it all hosted and you'd have
to size your servers to and to the
anticipated Peak load and if you don't
get the peak load then you're basically
wasting your investment but when you
have an elastic cloud and you use
compute resources as you need them
you're only going to pay for those so
from a business perspective you don't
have the initial investment the huge
upfront cost you can just have things
track with your usage and it turns out
to be a much much easier environment to
manage
okay in terms of definitions
this is another one of those slides
that's significant in terms of just you
know kind of defining what is
infrastructure as a service and what is
p platform as a service these are both
completely uh valid things to be using
and you can even use them at the same
time but they're different
philosophically so on the infrastructure
as a service side the main offering from
Google is called compute engine and this
is where you have raw compute power
storage networking and so on and it's
the closest analog to what we're used to
you know in our physical world so if you
think about a machine a computer that
you've got and maybe you're building it
yourself or you're ordering the parts or
you you order the complete computer in
the computer is the motherboard is the
chip is the ram are the disks and so on
and so compute engine and infrastructure
is a service is the cloud equivalent of
that so you literally can go and say Hey
I want a particular computer I want to
have this much memory in it and all
we're doing is going to a web page and
clicking options and we're building an
abstract computer this way and because
we're essentially taking things off the
shelf we're saying okay I want a
particular disc it's the size nobody
else can use it it's ours well I want a
CPU with so much power it's our CPU and
nobody else can use it we're taking it
off the shelf essentially so the fair
thing to do is for Google to charge you
for what you've requested and so that's
the pay for what you allocate even if
you don't completely utilize it you can
build a up a computer and they'll charge
you per hour or actually per minute for
all the resources that you've requested
platform as a service is a different
philosophy here you are supplying your
business logic and Google is taking care
of a lot more of the details they'll
give you run times it's a kind of a
Sandbox environment and they will scale
things for you automatically so the fair
thing to do is to charge you for the
resources you use at that moment so if
you need 100 app engines to support your
your requests or if you need just one
Google will scale that up and down and
you'll only pay for the amount of
compute power and resources that you're
using minute by minute
okay so across the whole Cloud platform
these are the major categories there's
compute power there's storage there's a
bunch of products focused on big data
and the new innovation area and where
Google is working very very hard is
machine learning and we'll we'll learn
about that near the end of the course
okay so talking about compute here we've
even got three options so we've got app
engine we've got container engine and we
have compute engine app engine is the
most constrained environment you do not
have much flexibility in terms of what
you can do but the benefit is by
constraining your application to only
the business logic you really only write
the business logic Google takes the
responsibility for everything else
making sure the software is updated
patching scaling taking care of all the
infrastructure
again on the far right side this is the
infrastructure as a service you're going
to be building your computers you need
to worry about how big they need to be
and do the scaling and so on but Google
still takes care of a lot of things they
will actually move a virtual machine to
a different bit of Hardware as it's
running in case they need to do
maintenance so there still is a huge
benefit even at this level of you know
defining computers to have it run in the
cloud
container engine is kind of in the
middle it's a level above virtual
machines uh container engine is all
about very lightweight Docker containers
coming to life very quickly or scaling
up or scaling down so again there's no
one ideal choice
and also in storage you can see the same
thing there's no one ideal choice for
storage we've got big table we've got
cloud storage that we're going to look
at in detail we're going to look at
Cloud SQL a relational database and
cloud data store a very unique data
mechanism that scales alongside of app
engine
on the big data side and again these are
all completely managed Services there's
bigquery it's extremely high performance
fast SQL language data processing system
it's great at reading log files and
giving you an idea of what's going on in
your application it's great at
processing all sorts of information and
it will even ingest information as it's
occurring so you can think of Internet
of Things devices sending information to
bigquery and you can be doing near
real-time analysis of all that data
Pub sub is a very simple idea it's about
sending messages to people who are
interested in what you're saying and
it's Google scale it'll take you know
million messages per second and it's
also a great decoupling tool in terms of
architecture
data flow is very Innovative this is
essentially generation two of mapreduce
I'm told that people at Google don't
actually use mapreduce anymore they all
use data flow and dataflow incorporates
the idea of mapreduce plus a lot of
other things and again we're going to
have some detailed slides on all of
these coming up dataproc is essentially
Hadoop managed by Google the value add
by Google is it can spin a cluster up in
90 seconds and it can resize it as your
workload is going so it minimizes your
cost and it's designed to be compatible
with Hadoop processing outside of the
cloud or in other clouds so you can just
bring your Hadoop processing run it on
dataproc and you can take advantage of
the Google platform data lab is a
notebook-like presentation of big
information so you can have it execute
queries you can do Graphics you can put
it into a notebook like format and then
give it to someone who wants to
understand the results of all this
processing
and the Machine learning side this is
really I think this is particularly
exciting we've made some major advances
in machine learning you probably know
that Google has a machine Learning
System that beat the world's expert in
the go go game
and what you do is you build up a set of
definitions in machine learning and then
train the system to do a particular task
so Google has done the training already
in some areas they have a vision API
that can recognize uh things in a
picture it can tell like if your pet is
a cat or a dog which is pretty
interesting there's General machine
learning so you can build your own
models they designed a speech model so
that it can recognize speech and there's
another model for translation between
languages so you can build your own
models or you can take some of these
existing ones and incorporate them in
your application
okay so now we're going to have a lab
this first lab is going to guide you
through the steps to set up a
relationship with Google Cloud you're
going to set up an account and you're
going to create a project
projects are the container for
everything that you do in the cloud
so these will take you through the steps
you're going to need to have a credit
card and the credit card is not so that
you're going to be paying for things
it's for your so that Google knows your
identity
it wants to know exactly who you are and
then once you do that
you will select an option for a free
trial and upgrade your account you're
going to get three hundred dollars of
credit that's good for 60 days so the
the course that you're taking now
probably will use maybe two I I'd be
surprised if you more use more than five
dollars of that 300. so at the end
you're going to have a nice account
you'll have money left and you'll be
able to do a lot of experimentation in
the cloud
so
I'm going to bring up another
window here
and I'm going to go to my console
okay
go to this little icon in the upper left
hand corner with a three horizontal
lines if you click on that that pops out
a tray
the different areas of the cloud
and what I suggest is you go to billing
and you should see that you've got a
billing account
see here billing management for CP 300
there's it's linked to an account called
Randolph kale
your account your billing account will
be named something else
and you can then manage billing accounts
you can see that there's a billing
account the account ID that it's active
and here it says I've got nine projects
associated with that and I can say my
projects and see exactly what they're
connected to
so again I'm already in a relationship
with Google so I had I don't see exactly
what you're seeing
but see if you can go through those
areas and see if it's if it's active and
so on
is it necessary to write down the credit
card you need to enter the credit card
yes the credit card is required by
Google not so they can charge your
credit card but it's used for
identification
and you what you do is you enter your
credit card you set up like you say yes
please Bill me that means create a
billing account but then you immediately
say I will accept the free trial you get
300 of credit which is good for 60 days
if at the end of 60 days or when you've
used up to 300 your credit card will be
charged so do understand that so you may
want to turn things off we'll talk about
that how you can make sure that you're
not going to get charged the easiest way
is simply to delete your project you can
just go in and say I need this whole
project deleted and then there's nothing
active so you will not be charged
okay activating the cloud shell
let's take a look at that
I'm going to go to my home area
on my screen
and the cloud shell there will bring
here is this icon right here
so you notice in the upper right hand
corner there's a little picture of me
that identifies the account the
relationship with Google so that's me
with a particular account I actually
have about five accounts with Google so
I use this little photo to remind me
which one it is and if you go to the
left you'll see this little icon that's
the cloud shell
so let me pick
um
cp100 class let me switch over to that
and then I'm going to click
oh that's interesting the cloud shell is
not working
okay they they made a major change to
the the user interface yesterday in fact
this doubt down used to be over on the
right
um and I'm not sure what is going on I'm
gonna I'm gonna go off mute and see if I
can figure it out
first let me explain what's going on the
cloud platform is comprised of many
different Services Each of which has an
API structure so that you can access it
in fact everything is communicated
through a rest API
and they don't turn on all of the apis
when you create your project and you
first set up set up a relationship
because they they just want to save the
uh the compute power to set up
credentials and so on so I'm guessing
the thing that you need to do is to go
up here and click on this icon and bring
the tray out
and then go down to compute engine and
click on that and what you should see
then is not what I have you know I see
create an instance you will probably see
please wait we're setting up the compute
engine API
and once you do that they would Google
will set up the infrastructure they'll
set up the credentials they'll set up a
bunch of things like that so notice that
once I did that notice my cloud shell is
now open
uh that's what's happened they've made a
they've reset some things so you need to
go into the compute engine area just by
going into that area should turn on the
activation of the API it should turn on
the creation of credentials and then
it'll give you the cloud shell that I'm
now running that you can see in the
window
so Dale please try that and let me know
if that works
and I also want to add do not get
concerned about the amount of time we're
spending on this this is an absolutely
crucial lab this obviously gets everyone
set up to run all the other labs so we
will take as much time as required to
make sure that everybody's up and
running you have the accounts properly
set up and so on and we'll work through
the details with you
foreign
so the last thing you should be doing is
is creating a project
you're just creating a project called
cp100
I'm showing you on the screen that's the
last step of this lab
this lab is overview
and then introduction
and then register for the free trial
which is five steps and then create a
project which ends with the third with
step three on the final slide
let me go bring up a console and show
you
so you should be here
there should be a drop down
right here notice that first of all
there's the the icon that brings the
tray out and then I have some of these
pinned I can tell tell you about those
later but right here I've got a project
and if you click on that it says create
a project and this is where you put in
your your name and you and you get your
ID and so on so that's what you should
see if you're ready to embark on a
career path buzzing with excitement
Innovation and boundless possibilities
look no further then simply learns
Caltech postgraduate program in cloud
computing focusing on gcp this
comprehensive program equips you with
the knowledge and skills needed to
navigate the vast landscape of cloud
computing with unwavering confidence
Unleash Your Potential as you delve into
the depths of gcp architecture conquer
deployment models 45 security like an
impedetrable Fortress and master
migration strategies that leave elastic
impact discover how to harness the full
suit of gcp services to construct not
just scalable applications but true
masterpieces of Technology don't let
this once in a lifetime opportunity slip
through your fingers ignite your career
and join the ranks of triumphant cloud
computing professionals click the link
in the description to uncover the
wonders of this course here we will
learn about Google Cloud web hosting
some basics of cloud computing web
hosting service providers what is gcp
and why go for it different types of web
hosting which are possible a use case
such as Lush and a quick Hands-On on
using gcp for web hosting
when you talk about Cloud web hosting
Google cloud has the feature of hosting
a secure and reliable websites easily it
ensures customers and sites protection
the website is a is hosted on a fast and
reliable Network
you can do more work for Less Price with
Google Cloud
now when we talk about Google Cloud it
is always good to know some Basics over
cloud computing now when we talk about
cloud computing cloud computing is
basically using resources which are
provided by your cloud service provider
such as Google cloud and cloud computing
basically means using hardware and
software components to deliver a service
on a network now here users can access
files applications from any device that
can access Internet so when we talk
about cloud computing this is basically
using Services which are hosted on the
infrastructure managed by cloud provider
when we talk about resources which can
be used that may include big data
services storage options your Computing
options networking options and various
other services which a cloud provider
offers
cloud computing has various different
service models such as you have platform
as a service software as a service
infrastructure as a service also these
days we talk about containers as a
service and these are your different
Computing service models which are being
offered by cloud service providers which
allow you for automatic integration with
your existing environment or if you
would want to benefit from modernization
by using a cloud provider's
infrastructure
you have different Services which are
offered some of them are for auto
software integration or migration
backing up and restoring data scaling
your storage capacity that is going for
an unlimited storage capacity and using
a resource provided by cloud service
provider benefiting from reliability
cost efficiency which is offered by a
cloud provider in this case we are
talking about Google Cloud when you talk
about web hosting service providers
there are various web hosting service
providers you have AWS you have
Squarespace IBM Cloud GoDaddy Bluehost
and Google Cloud
so what is gcp and why go for it
when you talk about gcp or as we call it
as Google Cloud platform it is set of
Cloud Computing Services provided by
Google that runs on the same
infrastructure that Google uses for its
end user products like YouTube Gmail and
much more when you talk about gcp there
are various reasons why anyone would
choose it for their use cases now let's
look at some reasons when you talk about
pricing gcp has better pricing compared
to its competitors depending on the
services which you would use whether
that would be infrastructure as a
service such as using compute engine
instances and running your applications
on them or might be a managed service
such as data proc or bigtable or your
bigquery where you can have your Hadoop
clusters running or store huge amount of
data or even build your data warehouse
where then you can store structured data
so there are different Services which
gcp offers and pricing has been a better
option in case of Google in comparison
to other competitors
when you talk about Speed and
Performance it's very fast and increases
the performance of your project if you
use different services offered by Google
when you talk about live migration of
apps this is one of the features which
organizations usually like which none of
other competitors are offering when it
comes to live migration of apps so there
are specific features for example when
you talk about compute engine there is a
feature stating live migration wherein
your resources or your instances which
are running applications would be
migrated during say maintenance from one
underlying host to another underlying
host without affecting your
application's performance and you can
benefit from that
when you talk about Big Data Google
cloud has various offerings in Big Data
space and that's one of the advantages
of gcp in comparison to other
competitors you have different services
for your big data needs such as Pub sub
for publish subscribing messaging system
or going for data proc which basically
allows you to spin up your Hadoop and
Spark clusters to run your different
jobs and so on so when we talk about
features of Google Cloud platform it
offers High productivity because you are
using the resources which are based on
the same infrastructure which Google
uses for its own different use cases you
can work from anywhere provided you have
internet connection and you can connect
to the cloud platform and use different
services offered via web you can quickly
collaborate with different teams or
different colleagues working on
different projects which might be
sharing or using the different GCB
resources you are benefiting from high
security and different encryption and
security mechanisms with gcp offers now
there are fewer sources or you could say
data which is stored or vulnerable
devices there is high reliability
flexibility or scalability which gcp
offers and the cost Effectiveness really
makes it as a good choice when you would
want to benefit from infrastructure
modernization and using a cloud platform
solution for your use case now when you
talk about different types of web
hosting Google Cloud offers three types
of web hosting you have WordPress now it
is a free and open source content
management system you might have used in
past or have heard about WordPress where
a lot of websites are being created it
is a popular web publishing platform to
easily set up blogs and websites and
thus used by organizations or even
individual users for having their blogs
or running their websites or promoting
their products you have lamp which
stands for Linux Apache MySQL and PHP
and lampstack consists of Linux Apache
HTTP server MySQL and PHP and is used to
host websites and web applications
you also have your option of building
your own website so you can develop
website or web application with your own
code directly on compute engine now
let's look at a use case and understand
what happened here when we talk about
Lush so less was founded in 1995 it's
you might have seen this brand somewhere
in the streets it is a global Cosmetics
retailer headquartered in UK it sells a
diverse range of fresh handmade products
less had become a global brand with over
930 stores in 49 countries so the
challenges which were faced here was
traffic on boxing day caused website
crash for almost 18 hours and this is
something which had a devastating effect
on their business the previous platform
had no scalability option what was the
solution the movement of website during
the peak time was easy due to
flexibility of gcp platform with rapid
VM deployment on Google compute engine
the environments were monitored and
destroyed in minutes so the team could
test and deploy at speed by using Google
Cloud SQL lust took complete control of
its infrastructure and optimize its
systems for Effective scaling overall
the platform resulted in lower cost that
led to a bright future for Less
Cosmetics now what was the result of all
this the availability during Peak loads
was improved because of Google compute
engines Auto scaling feature the
infrastructure hosting costs were
reduced by 40 percent streamline data
center usage from 5 to 3 with Google's
high quality private Network really
benefited Lush and it provided a
flexible architecture and scalability
for future business growth now what we
have seen here is that your Google cloud
and its web hosting basically offers
user search to run their websites or use
a web hosting solution that can benefit
in more than one way the simplest
approach could be seen is by clicking
and setting up a VM instance by going to
your console for example if we go in to
the Google Cloud platform clicking on
console
and here the easiest way I could test it
is by going to my compute engine VM
instances and here I can spin up an
instance I can click on create now in my
previous sessions I have also explained
about how you could create a template
and run an instance from that we can
also click on new VM instance let's call
it new instance I will choose a region
for example Frankfurt I will let it be
general purpose machines let this
machine be one virtual CPU core and 3.75
gigabyte RAM if I'm looking for a
heavier website which might have more
users logging in and so on then I can
choose a higher configuration machine
here we have the option to choose our
distribution so for example I can choose
Ubuntu and then I can choose a
distribution version so it let it be
16.04 we can choose the disk size to be
20 gigabyte and we can use ssds or hdds
so as of now it is standard persistent
disk that is STD and that should be
enough let's click on select here I will
say allow default access I would say
allow HTTP and https so that if I have a
website content hosted on this machine I
can access it over HTTP now here you
have management options for your
instance you have security option which
basically allows you to provide a public
key if you are interested in using an
external SSH client to connect now I
have used puttygen and I have already
created a private key which is here I
have also converted that as a pem file
and anytime if I would want to use this
key all I need to do is click on
puttygen where I had earlier created
this PPK file now I can just do a load
and I can choose the key which I have
here
and I can give the pass face click on OK
and that shows you the public key let's
copy the public key from here let's go
into our instance and I can give this
here that resolves the name so I have
the private key saved on my machine and
public key which will be pushed into the
machine I can click on Create and that
should create my instance to which you
can connect using SSH from the console
itself or using a external client such
as putty which will then need the public
IP of this instance the PPK file what we
have and you can connect to this
instance what I can also do is I can
just do a simple SSH from here and that
will basically allow me to connect to
the instance what we also need to
remember is each instance what we create
in compute is also having some default
firewall rules now I have connected to
my instance I can click on sudo SU I can
login as root and here if I would want I
can install a particular service so
let's say Apache let's say apt-get
install and then I can say Apache 2 or
httpd that is basically to host your web
application so I'm installing the
service
and here I can check if the service is
running by doing a service HTTP D status
or I can say service Apache 2 status
which says it is already running that
means the Apache web server page will be
accessible from HTTP provided my
firewall rules allow that now before we
look into this we can also for our
instance look at the firewall rules so
here you have Network details now since
we created an instance by default Google
has created some firewall rules which
allow default HTTP https
icmp your default internal access RDP
and SSH access and here it says these
Ingress rules which allow incoming
traffic are allowed from anywhere we can
customize that as specific IP addresses
we can also look at egress which is
basically outgoing traffic and this is
again saying my machine can connect to
that external World in different ways
using different protocols so you can
customize these firewall rules as of now
I am going to let it be default now be
connected to our instance from the
browser and we were basically checking
how you can use this browser by clicking
on this now what I can also do is here
I'm logged into the instance my Apache
server is running so the best way to
check if the Apache web server is
accessible vhttp all I need is my public
IP so let's copy this let's go here and
I will say HTTP slash slash just give
your public IP and that shows your
Apache to web server page that means the
Apache service has already been run now
here it tells if you would want to host
a particular page what you will have to
do is as it says here it is based on
equivalent page on dbn from which Ubuntu
Apache packaging is derived if you can
read this page it means Apache HTTP
server is installed and this site is
working properly now you can replace
this file located at VAR
www.html
index.html before continuing to operate
your HTTP server so this is where you
can change the particular page and you
will be able to host your web site on
this particular ec2 instance what we can
do is we can can check this so we can go
into the browser and we can look in VAR
www and that has an HTML folder look
into this and as of now you have a index
dot HTML and that basically is the page
what we are seeing now I can click on
this one and I can see I have a small
HTML page which is basically showing me
what we are seeing on our web server
what I can also do is for now I can test
it out and I can put in a different HTML
page and see how that works so we had
basically the page here in VAR www and
then we had the HTML folder and in HTML
folder what I had was this index file so
as of now I just moved it and I put it
in a different location so if I look in
my home hdu
index.html that shows me the complete
HTML page what we were seeing on our web
server and here it shows you what this
page would display if you run it on your
HTTP it says Apache to Ubuntu default
page it shows it works it shows the
content and so on so for just testing I
move this page out from this location
and what I did was I added a different
page here so that page if you look in
HTML and then look in my page.html
section I've just added some basic
details of creating HTML I'm saying body
I'm using Marquee and then I'm closing
this with HTML tag now this is a simple
HTML page which I created
and now what I did was once I've done
this I basically did a service Apache
restart so once you do that it will take
up your new page
and once you have done that now you can
access that by going to your HTTP
given your details and then basically
give your public IP which we can get
from here
and just paste it here now hit on this
so that shows me there is a my page.html
I can click on this and that basically
shows the symbol page which I created so
as of now this is my web page which I've
created and this is hosted on my compute
instance now obviously we can create a
more complex website backed up by a
database use PHP use MySQL to store the
data and then host your website on a
Google Cloud platform service such as
compute where your actual code is
running so we can learn about your web
hosting on compute instances in further
sessions here we wrap up with Basics if
you like this video hit the like button
consider subscribing to our Channel and
hit the Bell icon to never miss updates
from Simply on till then keep watching
and keep learning staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in Cutting Edge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign